hi drew i'm today atkins and i'm
america's youngest certified yoga
teacher when i started on my mission i
was just six years old at the time my
mom was just diagnosed with stage three
non-conscious lymphoma cancer it wasn't
until after she beat cancer that she was
first introduced to yoga she couldn't
walk on her own she couldn't bend or
straighten her knees afterwards she was
back to her healthy happy self but even
better my mom inspires me because she's
such a strong and loving person to me
and to everyone she always made sure to
help out any families who couldn't
afford yoga classes free yoga to cancer
patients and survivors so selfless so
generous really inspired me to do the
same so my mom and i started traveling
the country taking yoga teacher
trainings i started teaching my own
classes when i was 10 years old i'm now
500 hour vinyasa certified and have
almost 1 000 hours of teacher training
experience one piece of advice that i
would give for other people who are
trying to share their mission and use
their voice is to just not stop sharing
what you believe in even if people tell
you that you shouldn't talk about it or
if it's not really a popular belief just
keep on using your voice
thank you drew